cynthia millen has spent three decades
as a u.s swimming official but she has
just resigned in protest over
transgender swimmer leah thomas of the
university of pennsylvania who is a
biological male that has been allowed to
compete against females
thomas is now dominating swimming events
and setting records
in a resignation letter millen simply
said she quote can't support this and
that quote everything fair about
swimming is being destroyed
cynthia millen joins me now cynthia
listen thank you for joining me on the
show and thank you for your bravery i
guess i'm just curious what kind of um
response have you gotten since you know
you resigned
from your position
sean thanks very much i've gotten a lot
of kind comments from fellow officials
former officials and from parents of
swimmers and swimmers
the fact is that swimming is a sport in
which bodies compete against bodies
identities do not compete against
identities and from the very beginning
when you start out as an age grouper
swimmers are divided by sex and by age
group 8 and under 9 10 etc all the way
up because from the very beginning
swimming usa swimming recognizes that
boys swim differently from girls and
this is just accentuated when boys and
girls go through puberty boys will
always have larger lung capacity larger
hearts greater circulation a bigger
skeleton and less fat girls go through
puberty and they have a double whammy
they not only grow breasts and hips but
they have periods and they often have a
totally different center of gravity they
have to learn how to swim over again
so while leah thomas is a child of god
he is a biological male who is competing
against women and no matter how much
testosterone suppression drugs he takes
he will always be a biological male and
have this advantage and it's horrible
the statement for women then is
you don't matter
what you do is not important and little
girls are going to be thrown under the
bus by all of this he's going to be
destroying women's swimming
cynthia's so true and i guess my next
question for you is you know young women
who push back against you know
biological males competing in their
sport they can be bullied the social
media blowback can be great
but you look to you know moms across
america moms of athletes or you look to
pro athletes or olympic athletes who
competed in these sports
as women to stand up for girls today to
compete against other women are you
seeing that kind of mother support or
other kind of athletes in the olympics
that stand up and support this movement
to say biological girls should compete
against biological girls and biological
boys should compete against biological
boys
well it's it's great sean i'm getting
great letters from dads of daughters and
also moms of daughters but we're also
seeing some past olympians stepping up
and saying no this is wrong
we are we must remember that our olympic
swimming for women was built on great
swimmers like jill turkle
shirley babushoff janet evans jenny
thompson all of these women who worked
so hard before title nine when they
didn't have the opportunities that men
had and it would be such a shame it
would be such a travesty to throw it all
away now and this is what will happen we
must face facts men are different from
women
men swimmers are different from women
and they will always be faster than
women
you know cynthia as a as a father of not
of of of six girls i have nine kids six
are girls uh thank you for standing up
for girls uh to actually have the
ability to compete and win when they
compete against other girls and i hope
that every every mother out there every
father out there every olympic swimmer
or any woman athlete stands up and
stands with you to say this is wrong uh
and it's unfair and thank you for
letting your voice to this cause and
standing up and and and resigning in
protest you're a great american
thank you very much sean hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else